we turn now to the White House where
President Biden put on a tux and hosted
a state dinner last night for India's
prime minister Narendra Modi it followed
a day of flattery and pageantry showing
that the U.S sees India as an important
Ally in Asia a counterbalance really to
China's growing military and economic
power and it's a position and an
approach that some of the president's
supporters do not agree with Ed O'Keefe
is at the White House Forest following
all of it Ed good morning Good morning
Tony good to see you the White House
rolled out the red carpet for the Indian
Prime Minister last night but his visit
not without controversy because prime
minister Narendra Modi was once banned
from entering the United States due to
his human rights record
thank you
a night of Glitz glamor and a tribute to
the U.S India relationship two great
Nations and two great Powers cheers
roughly 400 invited guests including
lawmakers business Executives designer
Ralph Lauren who made the first lady's
gown and Biden family members including
the president's son Hunter who announced
a plea deal this week with Federal
prosecutors
a performance from violinist Joshua Bell
kept a full day that included an address
to Congress
India U.S friendship
thank you
an event boycotted by some democratic
lawmakers concerned that under Indian
Prime Minister Narendra modi's
leadership his government his undermined
elections press Freedom the judicial
system and the rights of the country's
Muslim minority we're talking about
Sikhs
Muslims Christians all of these
minorities having their rights stripped
but in a rare q a session with reporters
Modi disputed that his government
discriminates against religious
minorities
in India's Democratic Values there is
absolutely no discrimination neither on
basis of gas greed and President Biden
was asked whether his decision to call
Chinese leader Xi Jinping a dictator
this week could complicate U.S China
relations and his plans to meet with she
later this year I expect to be meeting
with President XI sometime in the future
in the near term and I don't think it's
had any real consequence
now we know what you're wondering about
what was on the menu last night well
since Prime Minister Modi is vegetarian
the White House recruited a
california-based chef to prepare
plant-based menu including stuffed
mushrooms and risotto with an option for
sea bass and for dessert everyone was
served Gail the Strawberry Shortcake
maybe one of these days you and I will
get our our invitation to one of these
fancy things we'll see yes you're
absolutely right I was actually
wondering what the menu was I would have
had the sea bass but it might have asked
for a little bit of chicken but
everybody likes a strawberry shortcake
Ed thank you always good to see you
thanks